this very moment of time and space is
occupied by everything that exists you
me and everything in between we are all
experiencing this same moment and we are
all experiencing this same moment
differently even if you and I were to
look out the exact same window at the
exact same street at the exact same time
it is likely that we would both see and
experience something different perhaps
you might enjoy watching all the people
walk by and musingly ponder about where
they could all be coming from and where
they could all be going and perhaps I
might look at all the traffic and become
tense with anticipation of the chaos
that I will be faced with when going
outside to commute somewhere or perhaps
you see the latter and I see the former
regardless it is likely that we both
have two different meant and experiences
of the same thing at the same time but
how is this possible how can we live on
the same planet sharing the same reality
looking at the same objects yet all have
different experiences
we all have uniquely coded DNA and we
all have unique paths with unique
upbringing z' influences and
environmental conditions all of these
factors and perhaps some others work
together to form the lens out of which
we see the world and experience the life
that engulfs us and it is this lens that
we form our self-identity out
how we view and feel about things is all
we know it is our truth and for our
truth and identity to be challenged is
to feel the existential sting of a
thousand bees and as a result everyone
has something to say about everything
and everyone likes to think that they
are right but yet we are often all
saying different and conflicting things
and so perhaps sometimes just because we
know we are right does not always mean
that we are amidst the world there are
countless ideologies philosophies and
perspectives that simultaneously exist
in direct conflict with each other
there is Catholicism and atheism monism
and Judaism nihilism and existentialism
and endless more all very different yet
equally as real and true to those who
behold them the spectrum of ideologies
in life is unending and overwhelming
what is the right one how do we know can
we know and if not should we even
subscribe to anything at all in general
an ideology is simply a system of
beliefs and theories on how to live or
function but that is it and problems
arise when we let our identity and ego
become so deeply ingrained in a
particular ideology that we neglect to
remember that that is all it is that it
is not a rigid and universal fact of
life it is just ideas theories and
principles constructed in an attempt to
combat the inexorable uncertainty and
complexity of human life
truthfully we are all in conflict with
understanding the life around us and
when forming our beliefs and
perspectives our goal should not be to
subscribe permanently and exclusively to
something that sets limitations for
ourselves or others regarding what we
can experience believe and consider
there is no universally correct ideology
perhaps there are some that consistently
hit closer to the sweet spot of common
sense but there is currently no
one-size-fits-all there are too many
variances in the nature and nurture of
individuals for everyone to agree on one
ideology and life is too complex for one
ideology to apply to every facet of life
if life is complex and constantly in
flux so should we be along with our
beliefs and perspectives true
intelligence comes with the admission of
ignorance and the admission of our
incomplete pursuit of knowledge and
understanding intelligence is to engage
in discussion with other opinions ideas
and perspectives and consider them for
what they are with openness and reason
if we want truth we must be willing to
pull from varying ideologies
however dogmatically contradictory they
may be we must be able to consider
individual concepts and issues for what
they are using a combination of
scientific understanding empirical
evidence self-knowledge personal
reflection and reason
and we must do so not seeking to see if
they fit within our existing beliefs and
ideologies but to simply find the most
accurate and applicable answers to our
questions
to move fluidly with life and not get
left behind in our stalls of expired
self-righteousness
[Music]
thank you for watching if you found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel we are constantly coming out
with new videos to help you experience
life with clarity and Wonder